I want to start by showing you this
image I hope you all enjoy this uh this
picture uh we'll have to uh we'll have
to open image in a new tab and then
we'll have to shrink it so you can
actually see it wow this is uh there you
go it's very tiny on the screen because
uh you can't
actually scroll around or whatever and
but uh there you go it's uh it's Donald
Trump and it says revenge on it breaking
Trump to a point special counsel to
investigate Biden family corruption if
re-elected this is the reason people
want to vote for Donald Trump you want
revenge I'll vote Trump I'd like Revenge
what do you guys think I would like
justice and if that means forgiveness
and compassion along with it Mercy
apparently what does that depends on if
it's Greek or Latin right yeah it's a
Greek I go with the Greeks on these that
yeah let me tell you a story Ian
Donald Trump said that he would uh
criminally indict Hillary Clinton that
he would go after she'd be in jail and
then what was it two days after he got
elected he's like no no we're not gonna
do that it's okay
Donald Trump should have gone after all
of these people with criminal charges
because they're corrupt evil individuals
and he didn't because he said we're
gonna forgive
we're gonna be like you Ian we're gonna
forgive everybody and now they're
arresting us lawyers I wish he'd said
that he never really talked about
forgiveness he still talked crap
he didn't he didn't he didn't prosecute
he didn't direct his doj to rescue
nobody didn't like make good he just
told Hillary talk crap about him through
her I mean they all do it and then he he
didn't go after her yeah yeah he should
have because he said you should probably
be in jail and he she wasn't and she
also denied the election too yeah so to
an extreme degree yeah she what was it
she uh was it her campaign or the
dancing that funded the seal dossier it
was her campaign yeah her campaign it's
creating the lie that Donald Trump was a
Russian spy
yeah Stacy Abrams how come she's not in
jail right I love exactly Brian Kemp is
like for the past three years no one has
brought any any evidence of voter fraud
I'm Like You mean past five years
because like you're excluding Stacy
Abrams what I actually said was yeah but
you stole the election from Stacey
Abrams you Russian Nazi
well do you really I mean you're allowed
to question elections in the United
States
he's getting prosecuted for doing just I
mean that might be one of the things but
it's the it's the Gen six it's that's
not literally it Georgia is not going
after him over January 6th they're not
going after his lawyers for January 6th
but George is why this whole charade
began is no no Georgia is going after
none of the charges related to January
6th and Georgia Georgia has no
jurisdiction there they're charging
Trump and his lawyers for reaching out
to State Legislature uh one of one of
the acts is that they they reached at
lawyers reached out to the legislature
and said you guys should vote on this
and choose who you think should actually
win based on the discrepancies they said
that solicitation of a violation of oath
of office
not January 6th they're saying because
Donald Trump had lawyers go and make the
legal argument that they should take the
Constitutional path of upholding their
their absolute legislative power to
determine who gets the electors they
said so that's a violation Stacey Abrams
do that did Hillary have lawyers go talk
to electors I don't know
um so the Democrats had alternate
electors and faithless electors you're
also just now you're just arguing to
degrees not whether or not I'm arguing
that you're allowed to question
elections the United States again we're
the point is that's why Trump is not
allowed to because Trump is being
prosecuted and Stacey Abrams has done
this and Hillary Clinton has already
done it in a way it's the way Trump
questions
there are ways that can get you thrown
in jail of questions and Jenna Ellis one
of the indicted co-conspirators was only
charged on counts one and two which is I
think violating the oath of public
office and Rico they're literally saying
because she worked for Trump she's
guilty of conspiracy that's it
that's it now other people were charged
with like solicitation of the violation
of office specific things but they're
going after her quite literally just
because she worked for Donald Trump as a
lawyer
so no
you don't get to call a lawyer and now
you the it looks like the federal
government's gonna do the same thing
they're going to go after Rudy Giuliani
and Sydney Powell and a bunch of these
people if you if you guys go out and
tell everyone you can't question
elections in the United States anymore
you turned us into a totalitarian state
we did don't do it exactly you gotta
keep in the face say it I mean we did no
I'm saying if you go out and start
telling people you can't do this anymore
you've become a hand of the state you
don't want to become that guy that's
black pilled and tells everyone it's
over you can question elections the
United States
to do that oh go ahead no good good yeah
no what you're saying is is like we
can't run around and tell people that
you can't question the elections right
right you can do that but no okay of
course you can question the election and
then if you take any actions and
furtherance of your questions you'll be
criminally charged sure it depends on
how but possible like you could
literally just be the lawyer for Donald
Trump and they'll charge you with
conspiracy yeah but I think my theory or
my hypothesis if he hadn't told people
to go to the Capitol on Jan six none of
this would be happening right now and
peacefully protest
many other groups and organizations did
that worse like I'm not saying it was
right but I'm also saying there's other
organizations and groups that did that
also
at the Capitol like they burnt down a
church or they tried to burn or they
tried to burn down a church they set
fire where's the RICO charges for
anything that was organized and planned
they were all let off of all charges we
still have guys that are still in jail
from January 6 that that were I thought
just to say the hot dog cart across the
street I mean come on
there's got to be a point where
everybody on both sides is like all
right this is nuts right or no I think
so no I hope so there is not I mean I
that's why I'm into pardons I think of
it is if you don't care if you really
don't find some kind of uh like
spiritual fulfillment and finding your
enemies like forgiven if you don't get
that then think of it as a hostage
negotiation and you want those Jan six
prisoners out so you pardon them and
then you want Hunter Biden pardoned as
the hostage prisoner exchange yeah think
of it as a prisoner exchange that's why
you issue Mass Pardons and maybe Society
will freak out maybe it won't maybe it
has to come from the top maybe it has to
come from the people first I don't know
but it can't happen I kind of think of
it more like there's a guy running
around setting fires and Ian is like if
you please promise not to do it again we
won't put you in jail
it's like well I don't know about that
yeah it's like saying I'm not gonna put
you in jail for all those fires you
started if you do it again you're done
but I'm we're moving forward let's not
anyone light any more of those that
that's kind of the mentality
um
with the with the hope that they won't
and then what happens when they do
um well that's a loaded question if if
they do uh then you have to put them in
prison that you can't just keep yeah
yeah we can't keep playing the game
got it
I don't know
it's wild to me that's all
well what what what's what's the next
step I mean we've got a couple months
away a couple we've got maybe I don't
know
seven months until we start going to the
primaries I think we got to record a
million to one because we need to become
a cultural center
that's a song
the song I wrote that Ian really likes
it's the best song It's Your Best song
that so far and it's just the beginning
so full disclosure I just started
following your music oh love it thank
you I agree it's great I don't believe
it's that important I believe building
culture is important because laws are
only enforced on cultural grounds
confidence is everything yeah if people
didn't have confidence in the dollar
nobody would take the dollar which is
why the US gives dollars to all to
countries all over the world for garbage
nonsense and that's why I say that um
voting Republican is good because you
need actions within the government to to
alter policy and things like that but
for the most part what's going to change
this is building culture yeah rich men
north of Richmond it there the corporate
press is attacking it as a far right
wing yeah industry plant fake blah blah
blah he's like the most genuine guy just
a video of a guy singing like I don't
even like that's the best thing for it
though but who cares if it's an industry
like maybe this guy got signed a long
time ago and said we're gonna put up a
music video and ask people to promote it
I'm like okay it's a good song yeah it's
a nice day the the left the people that
are attacking it
are the best thing for its credibility
oh yeah because the people that are
attacking it are doing exactly what he
says they're doing it's the it's the
champagne social the idea of the
champagne socialist the rich Urban
people and those are the people that
while they talk a good game about the
Working Man when a working man you know
or an ostensibly not wealthy not
Cosmopolitan person is sitting there
singing a song about the struggles that
they're noticing in their lives all they
do is dump all over him call him all
kinds of names and it really he really
the lyrics really do tap into things
that are on a lot of people's minds but
the people on the left I mean they feel
like it's attacking them and they're the
ones that are making it about them
because it doesn't specify a side left
or a side yeah obviously there's a whole
lot of you know insecure Purity when it
comes to the uh the remark about Epstein
Island and or the the line about Epstein
Island and stuff
um but it's not particularly right
leaning it in policy it's but it is
culturally right and that's why cultural
leftists really hate it and it you know
you can I enjoy reading the people that
hate on it because it's you know well
because it's like the people that like
you say something about but you're not
you didn't mention them by name but
they're guilty so they're like are you
talking about me yeah they feel quite
good so it's yeah totally about you
so
I I'm a big fan of I thought the song
was very simple if you haven't heard it
yet North Richmond north of Richmond um
it's first course first course pretty
basic but the guy's performance is out
of control we need we need that we need
like we need heart shattering sound to
to shake people out of this morose
yeah I mean like I said it speaks to
the the mistrust
of the average well of the establishment
by the average person you know and and I
think that that the fact that it
resonated so with so many people and and
went viral so fast and so viral so fast
I think that that's something that
really has worried The Establishment and
you have Rolling Stone crapping on a
proton all the crap on everybody well I
mean but they didn't always a protest
song That's supposed to be something
that Rolling Stone would get behind you
know it's protesting against the
government and and like you know in the
60s that would have been or the 70s
that's that would have been right up a
Rolling Stones alley they'd have been
right there cheering them on but they
weren't because they're The
Establishment right they're the
propaganda arm thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time